[MUSIC PLAYING]
VENKAT GATTAMNENI: My
name is Venkat Gattamneni.
I'm a product manager with GCE,
and welcome to the session.
It's an introductory session
on running Windows Server
containers in Google
Kubernetes Engine.
And presenting with
me are Yu-Ju and Alex.
I'll let them introduce
themselves quickly.
YU-JU HONG: Hi.
I'm Yu-Ju.
I'm a software
engineer at Google.
I have been working
on Kubernetes and GKE
for the past four years.
Most of my work is about
Node and continued runtime.
I'm Happy to be here today to
introduce you to Windows Server
Kubernetes on GKE.
ALEX IANKOULSKI: Hi.
My name is Alex Iankoulski
I'm a software architect
with the data science and
analytics team at Baker
Hughes, a GE company.
I'm a GCP customer.
VENKAT GATTAMNENI: Awesome.
Thank you so much,
Yu-Ju and Alex.
Before sort of, like,
we go into the session,
I just want to do a bit
of an audience poll.
Just show of hands,
how many of you
are using containers already?
Awesome.
And how many of you are sort
of new to containers, still
kicking the tires a little bit?
Great.
How many of you are using
Windows Server containers?
OK, OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
VENKAT GATTAMNENI: OK,
that's totally fine.
And how many of you
are excited to be here
to learn more about Windows
Server containers in GKE?
Yay, OK.
We're all in the
right session, then.
Awesome.
OK.
So what I'll do by way of--
by way of, agenda what
we'll do is we'll go--
so this is an introductory
session like I said before.
We'll go into a little bit of
a quick overview of Windows
Server containers.
And then we'll talk at length
about Kubernetes and GKE
and running Windows
Server containers in GKE.
But before we get into the
technical details, what
I wanted to do was
hear from Baker Hughes,
who is one of our largest
customers for GKE.
And they've been on a multi-year
journey to transform themselves
in using containers.
So let's hear from
Alex as to what they're
doing at Baker Hughes and
how Windows Server containers
fits into their
journey and strategy.
Alex?
ALEX IANKOULSKI:
Thank you, Venkat,
and I really appreciate
the fact that you're
letting me speak first,
as GCP traditionally does.
They put their customers first.
So just to give a little
bit of business context,
BHGE is the world's
first fullstream company.
That means a full stream, a full
service, oil and gas business.
We have about 66,000
employees and operations
in more than 120 countries.
Being fullstream means that
we deal with challenges
across the full spectrum of
services in the oil and gas
industry--
from exploration to production,
transportation, and operations.
We see and operate a lot of
mission critical equipment
and complex systems that
produce an ocean of data.
We like to say that we
operate and our challenge
is in the intersection of data
science, software, and domain
knowledge to help us build
accurate models from that data
and extract insights
that make and help
us make very high impact and
critical business decisions.
For example, a typical
oil rig produces
terabytes of data per day.
It can have upwards of 20,000
sensors that give information
to us every couple of seconds.
And our models cannot have
an impact that would cause us
to falsely shut down that oil
rig for a day because that
would equate to about $10
million in lost profit.
Traditionally, the
oil and gas industry
has been a data rich industry.
But that data is spread
around the business in silos.
There is a huge variety
of code and technologies
that have been used in the
industry over the past 30
years, and we have
analytics that
have been proven in the field.
But that over time has
accumulated a technology stack
that starts from Fortran 77
all the way to today's world,
where we have node JS, go, .NET.
So somehow, all
of these analytics
need to work together.
They have to be
orchestrated together,
pass data from one to another,
be orchestrated in loops.
That's a huge challenge.
The thing that makes it
possible and easier for
do that are containers.
If you'd like to
learn more about how
we run these analytics
in containers,
how we orchestrate
them at scale,
I invite you to join me
at this breakout session
tomorrow, where we're going
to dive deeper into that.
And here are some examples
where we see specifically
use of Windows-dependent
executables.
So we have legacy DLLs and
old compiled executables.
One example is this
steam thermal model.
That's a Windows
executable from '95.
And aren't spreadsheets great?
I many, people today still
do analytics in Excel.
Another good example is this
refinery simulation software
that we're trying to modernize.
And we were able to actually
transform part of it
into Linux container,
wrap a web UI around it.
But there's this one part
that is impossible to change,
and that is the
licensing server.
That only runs on Windows and
has to run on that platform.
We were able to put it
in a Windows container.
So I wanted to come on stage
here today so I can say this.
Ladies and gentlemen,
I have a dream.
I dream of a day
in the future where
we can say all containers
are created equal.
And at BHGE, we created this
project called Depend On
Docker, which makes it easy
for our data scientists
to containerize, both on
Windows and Linux, anything
that they're working on.
We've open sourced this.
Please check out the GitHub.
But that is not enough.
The Windows and Linux
containers that we build
need to work together
side by side.
And we need this WAN
orchestration system that
is going to do that for us.
So let me leave you with
the words of John Lennon.
You may say I'm a dreamer,
but I'm not the only one.
And with this, let me pass the
mic back to Vankat and Yu-Ju
from the Windows GKE team so
they can tell you how they're
making all of this happen.
VENKAT GATTAMNENI:
Thank you so much, Alex.
Let's now talk about making
Alex's dream a reality,
shall we?
Awesome.
So-- but jokes aside,
you know, outside,
of course, making sure that
we are listening to customers
and bringing Windows
Server containers to GKE,
this is also part of our
longstanding commitment
to make sure that, you
know, Microsoft workloads
get a first class
experience on GCP.
And this is a statement that you
see made by our SVP [INAUDIBLE]
that we are really
committed to making sure
that Microsoft workloads are
a first class citizen on GCP
and, of course, GKE as well.
Now for those of
you who said, hey,
you're still early in
considering Windows Server
containers, here's a
very quick overview
of Windows Server containers.
For those of you who've
been doing this for a while,
this should be all
obviously very familiar.
It's often good to
think of containers
in the context of virtual
machines if you're new to it.
On the left hand side is what
I presume everyone in the room
is familiar with, right?
Virtual machines.
Typically, virtually
machines were
invented to virtualize
the underlying hardware
or the infrastructure so
much so that each of the OS
and the application running
on top of the OS pretty much
thinks that it has the
hardware to itself.
And that was the
technology of hypervisor.
Now containers is
somewhat similar.
So it's good to think of
containers in that context
where the application and
the dependent binaries
that the application
depends on essentially
is the container, the red box
that you see on the right hand
side.
And those, of course,
many of those containers
can run inside of a
virtual machine in GCP.
Essentially, containers are
virtualizing the underlying
operating system so much so
that the application thinks
that it has OS to itself
whereas in reality, we all
know it's not.
So that's kind of like,
you know, quick overview
of what containers are.
And in the world of
Windows Server, containers,
they're very similar
to Linux containers.
Of course, there are a
couple of differences
that we'll kind of highlight
in the next few slides.
But you want to think
of a Windows Server
container on the right
hand side as consisting
of several layers.
Typically inside of
a virtual machine,
when you're running a Windows
Server container that's
in the red box, there is,
of course, a host OS, right?
That's a Windows Server
host OS that's running.
On top of that, there's a
container runtime like Docker.
And on top of that runs your
Windows Server container.
And a container, a
Windows Server container,
like you can see here, is
composed of multiple layers.
Typically, you know,
there's a base OS layer
image at the bottom, obviously.
And above that, there are
a number of custom layers
that you can add on top.
It can be IIS, Partial, et
cetera, et cetera, right?
A lot of things you can add
on top of the base OS layer.
And then on top of that
sits your application.
That, in a sense, is really
how you make containers, right?
windows Server containers.
Hopefully that was a quick
overview for those of you
who were early in the Windows
Server containers land.
Now as you make choice of
your Windows Server containers
and you make those containers
of your applications,
a couple of things I wanted to
kind of run by very quickly.
The first thing you'll be doing
is selecting your underlying
host OS.
Now as many of you may
know, from Microsoft,
there are two releases
or two channels
that Microsoft has for
Windows Server, one
they call Long Term
Service Channel,
and the other is called
semi-annual Channel.
LTSC, examples of that are
Windows Server 2016, 2019,
and so on.
And of course, on a semi-annual
channel release schedule,
these are released
every six months or so.
So the latest one is 18.09.
And usually, the
numbering or the
build numbering for that
follows the year and the month
after that, right?
So that's the key difference
between those two releases.
A couple of quick
things to note there--
if you are looking
into containers,
I'll point out the
support that Microsoft
provides for either of them
is a little bit different.
So you want to make your
choice for underlying host
OS based on that if
that's of importance.
But that said, there
is a lot changing
with the server containers.
In fact, updates
are being released
on a very frequent basis.
So the recommendation
from Microsoft
is obviously to use
the semiannual channel
for your container
applications because then you
can keep up to date with
all of that good tech that's
coming out and rolling into
these semi-annual updates,
right?
So that's kind of a little bit
about choosing the underlying
host OS.
Now going one layer
up, as you are choosing
your next layer of your
Windows Server container,
you have to make a choice
on what kind of a base image
you want inside
of your container.
There are two broad
types of base images
that you can choose from--
the Windows Server Core
and the Windows Nano Server.
The key differences between them
are, of course, one is of size.
For those of you who may
know, Windows Server Core,
when you download from the
registry, is a little over two
gig.
And of course, uncompressed,
it can go up to about five gig,
right?
Windows Nano Server, on the
other hand, is very tiny,
almost compares to
Linux container sizes.
When you download,
that's under 100 meg now,
and of course, when
you explode that up by,
it's a little bit over 200 meg.
Now the scenarios where
you'll be choosing either
or are going to be dependent
on your applications.
If you want a lot of
compatibility for your legacy
applications with
the older stuff,
you want to go for Server Core.
Of course, a lot of the new
applications like .NET core,
IIS, ASP.NET, et cetera, will
do just fine in Nano Server.
The usual rule of thumb
is go with Nano Server.
If for some reason,
compatible reason, you cannot,
of course go down
the left side, right,
with Windows Server Core.
So hopefully that's
a little bit of a tip
on choosing the next layer for
your Windows Server containers.
Now one of the things that
is kind of like a little bit
different in the world
of Windows Server
containers versus what you
may have been used with Linux
containers is that you
must make sure that you
have to match the host and
the container OS versions.
So you know, this is
just a bit of a gotcha,
if you're especially coming
from Linux world, to kind of,
like, make sure those two match.
And when it comes to
Windows Server numbering
system for versions, there
are four numbers, right?
There is major, minor,
build, and revision.
Now the first three are the
ones that have to match.
The last one, it's OK
for it not to match.
The revision number
is typically a number
that gets updated every time you
apply a patch, like a KB patch,
to your image.
So that's the key difference.
Just to illustrate
a quick example,
let's say if you have a
container image and host OS
version.
And those are the versions
that they're running.
If you end up, let's
say, upgrading or rather
applying a patch update
to the host OS version
and you don't update or
apply that same patch
to your container image,
it'll just work fine.
However, if you upgrade
the underlying host OS,
let's say, to next
build and you do not
do that for the container,
it just won't run, right?
Like, it's not even now--
it just won't even start, right?
So just kind of like something
to remember as you're
thinking about what
version to choose
and how to mix and match your
order sort of the container
and host versions.
Now we get a lot
of these questions
from customers also
on licensing, right?
How does licensing work
for Windows containers?
So I just wanted to spend a
minute on that now the way
Microsoft treats
container licenses is
that they are supplements to
the underlying host OS licenses.
What that basically means
is if you are running
a licensed holster
with inside of OEM,
you can run containers, right?
Your license actually
covers for that.
So the good news is in GCE,
as long as you're spinning up
your Windows Server
VMs, you're already
licensed for because
you're paying
for the license
on the underlying
sort of virtual machine.
You can run any number
of containers on top.
And because Windows Server
2019 Data Center and Standard
Editions allow you to run
unlimited number of Windows
Server containers,
there's a ton of savings
you can actually
get by packing a lot
of those containers on one OS.
The other key point I
want to sort of mention
here is if you are running
containers on top of a host OS,
you can only do that
for running containers.
So you can't have
some containers
and have something
else run on top also.
That's what on the right side
of the slide it says, right?
It has to be used solely
to run containers.
So that's kind of like a
licensing term as well.
So hopefully some tips
here on licensing.
Now of course, we get a lot
of questions from customers.
Many of you are thinking about
how to basically containerize,
what to containerize, what not.
Those are all great
discussions, and it's
hard to come up with a
prescriptive guidance
for that sort of a
question, honestly.
Just now you heard from
Alex as to the journey
that they have
embarked on, especially
as they sort of modernized
and containerized
their applications.
And your journey could be very
similar or very different,
honestly.
In many cases, what I do
recommend to customers
is that have a
bit of a checklist
that you prepare
for applications
and have some criteria by which
you assess those applications,
whether they are
containerizable or not.
And some, of course, tips
are here on the slide.
Great candidates for
containerization generally are,
you know, your web
and logic tiers,
in-house .NET apps if you've got
custom apps that you developed
yourself because you know the
code and you can containerize
them and, of course, slightly
more recent applications that
are perhaps IIS 6 Plus or 3.5
.NET framework and onwards.
And, of course, new
applications that you're
developing using
Microsoft's architectures
and/or cloud native
applications also
make for great candidates
for containers.
Now some of those
applications that you
want to stay away from for
a little bit, at least,
is any application that
has UI experience, right,
because containers
won't give you that.
RDP, VDI are examples kind of
like to stay away from for now.
And especially if there is
an underlying dependency
your application has on GPUs
or TPUs or any low level
networking constructs out
there, you want to kind of look
at it a little bit
more closely before you
decide to containerize.
And of course, with
AD integration,
that's something
that's in the works.
So I would say keep
looking out for that.
Upstream Kubernetes has
that in alpha support,
and of course, we will have
plans to support that as well.
But that's something to
absolutely keep on lookout for.
One thing I'll mention
here is that any
of the things that are
important to you that
are on the right hand side, due
talk to us because the world is
changing very quickly.
We're adding a ton of innovation
as is Microsoft as well
with containers.
So we're all listening
to your feedback.
So keep talking to us.
Now outside of that,
in Google Cloud
we've been, of course,
supporting Windows Server
containers for a while.
If you go to your management
console and open up the menu,
there are a number of
images already that you
can get started with today.
And if you choose one
of these container
optimized images
for Windows Server,
they come in with Docker
pre-installed, right?
So you don't have to
install Docker yourself.
They are ready to go.
And they have Server Core,
Nano Server images already
downloaded and loaded up in
the local registry inside
of those virtual machines.
So if you want to give
it a spin immediately,
you can do so without having
to download them on the wire
again.
And then, of course, GCP does
have a cloud registry for you
to kind of make modifications,
if you want, to those container
images, push and
pull those images
at your will, which
of course is going
to be a lot more important as
you look at Kubernetes and GKE,
of course, as well
for the applications.
And if you're interested in
learning a little bit more
about how do you take a .NET
application, containerize it,
et cetera, there is a session
that we're running later today.
We'll go into a little
bit more of depth
and show a demo
as well for that.
Now, obviously that
was a whirlwind tour
of hopefully Windows Server
containers and hopefully
some tips and tricks
for those of you
who are very early in
the journey with us.
Now let's shift our attention
to talk about orchestration
with Kubernetes.
Y-Ju will be covering a
little bit about Kubernetes
and then talking about our
plans to support it in GKE.
Yu-Ju?
Sorry.
YU-JU HONG: Yeah,
thanks, Venkat.
So in the next part,
I'll be walking you
through a high level overview
of Windows Server containers
with Kubernetes
and then with GKE.
And then I'll wrap
it up with a demo.
So if you don't know
about Kubernetes already,
it's the leading container
orchestration system out there.
It helps you automate
deployment of your applications,
managing your life
cycles, and scaling
your applications as needed.
So this technology was actually
inspired by Google's experience
of running billions
of containers
internally over the years.
And it's completely
the open source
and runs in multiple clouds.
So here's an oversimplified
view of Kubernetes architecture.
At the bottom, you
have the worker nodes,
which are typically
virtually machines
running your workloads.
And then you have the
master control plane
at the top that includes
API servers, scheduler,
and various controllers.
So a Kubernetes user would just
write a workload specification
indicating how many
replicas they want,
what kind of container
images to use, and then
submit this spec to
the API server, which
will get dispatched eventually
onto the worker nodes.
And then we have the per
node agent, which is kubelet,
that will start
off the containers
and manage them for you.
So Kubernetes started with
Linux containers only.
But in the past two
years, the community
has been working
closely with Microsoft
to support Windows containers.
So I'm happy to
tell you that just
in the last month in the
Kubernetes 1.14 release,
Windows Server containers
running on Windows nodes
were declared as
a stable feature.
So kudos to all the community
members who helped to make this
happen.
So how do Windows Server
containers work in Kubernetes?
So let's see an
overview of this.
So here, we have the
architecture again.
And you have the
master control plane.
So this master control plane
will still run on the Linux.
Currently, there's no plan
to make it run on Windows.
But then you can
add Windows nodes.
So those worker
nodes will be running
Windows Server 2019, which
is a requirement with a 1.14
release.
And then on those
nodes, again, we
will have per node
agents running.
So with the Windows nodes,
now you can run Windows pods.
So pod is composed of
multiple containers.
It's a basic scheduling
unit in Kubernetes.
So containers in a pod
share a single IP address.
They can share volumes to
access the same set of data.
And users can
customize their pods
to use custom hooks
or health checks.
And also, a pod can access
config maps or secrets which
are Kubernetes concepts
for configurations
or storing of
sensitive information.
And then, of course,
you can view the status
and getting the events and
metrics for your Windows pods
as you can do for
your Linux pods.
So with pods, now you
can build services.
A service in Kubernetes
groups multiple pods
with a defined access policy.
For example, as
shown on the slide,
you can have a service
with a single IP address.
And then you can actually
have three different pods
to back the service.
So the traffic would get
distributed onto those three
pods.
So Kubernetes supports multiple
types of services or load
balancers, and we support those
for both Windows and Linux
pods.
So this provides
cross-platform connectivity.
So we talk about pod, which
is a very basic concept
in Kubernetes.
But most users don't
create pods directly.
They create a higher level
construct that better
suits their work loads.
For example, a DaemonSet
would create a pod per node.
Or If you use Job,
it will ensure
that a number of desired
pause would run to completion.
And then we have
StatefulSet, which
provides stable network
and storage identity
for each pod in the set.
This is particularly
useful if you are
accessing a persistent storage.
And if the pod crashes or
if you recreate the pod,
you want the pod to
assume the same identity
and access the same
piece of storage.
So these are all supported
for Windows pods as well.
So we've only touched upon the
basic concepts in Kubernetes
and what's supported
for Windows containers.
There are so many other features
that are already supported
for Windows containers.
And again, there would be
some features that do not
work for Windows pods yet.
And it could be due to
the inherent limitation
on Windows kernel and
the platform or just
because a concept does not
exist on Windows at all.
And you will find in some
cases, even though a feature
does work for Windows,
the behavior on Windows
pods, there might be a
slight behavioral difference
between Windows
pods and Linux pods.
So there are things
to watch out for.
And of course, the
community is continuing
working on rolling out--
supporting different features.
And many more will be coming
in the next few releases.
So that's one incentive to
keep your Kubernetes cluster up
to date.
So if you are
curious and you want
to find out more about what
features are supported,
you can check out the
link on the slide.
This is a documentation
maintained by the Kubernetes
community.
It will get updated frequently.
Or if you don't
trust documentation,
we also have continuous testing.
This is our open source
testing dashboard
that's running Kubernetes
on Google Compute Engine
for Windows Server containers.
It runs regularly
every couple of hours,
and you can clearly see
what's working and what's not.
So Kubernetes is great,
and many people love it.
And it's widely used.
But a lot of users want
to focus on developing
their applications, not
managing the Kubernetes cluster,
figuring out the operational
logistics day to day.
And that's where GKE comes in.
GKE provides a fully
managed master control plan.
So you don't have to worry
about the downtime of your API
server.
You don't have to resize your
master control plane just
because you want to
scale your workload
or adding more nodes
into your cluster.
GKE also monitors the
health of your nodes
and provides auto
repair mechanism
if you want it and offers
different options for upgrade.
There's also logging, out
of box logging, monitoring
integration, and a lot more
integration with other Google
Cloud Services.
So we are working very hard
to bring Windows containers
support to GKE so that you
get to fully experience GKE
while running both Linux
and Windows workloads.
So here's a preview of how
Windows Server containers will
look like on GKE.
So again, the
architecture diagram--
but this time, we have
the masters in a cloud.
So that just means you don't
have to worry about it.
You don't need to care
about what's actually
running in there right now.
And in GKE, there's a concept
called node pool, which
basically is just
a group of nodes
with the same
configuration-- for example,
the same machine type,
the same OS image.
And so far, we've only been
supporting Linux node pools.
We'll be adding Windows
node pool support,
meaning that you could just
add the new Windows node
pool into an existing cluster.
And then you can run
mixed Windows and Linux
workloads in the same cluster.
So you may be
wondering, but what will
happen to my Linux workloads?
Will they get scheduled
onto those Windows node
and fail to run?
So to prevent that
from happening,
we'll be tenting the
Windows node automatically.
So tent is a common
mechanism used in Kubernetes
to steer the workflows away.
So any workflow that cannot
be run on Windows will be
automatically assigned
to Linux nodes.
This ensures a
backward compatibility
for your workloads.
So if you just want to create
a pod that runs on Windows,
what would you do?
So in this case,
all you need to do
is to add a node selector
to target Windows nodes.
And in GKE, we will add
the toleration for you
so that it can get
scheduled onto Windows node.
And remember that I mentioned
previously that some
of the features work
for Windows, some don't.
And it's actually a
very complicated process
and documentation
to look through.
To help with our
users, we'll also
be validating the
fields in the passback,
making sure that the
features you are using
are actually supported.
And if not, we'll
reject right away so
that you know what's going
on with your workload.
So enough with the talking,
and let's see it in action.
So I'll be doing a demo
with a GKE cluster today.
And sorry, can you
go back to the slide?
Can we switch back to
the slide one second?
SPEAKER 1: [INAUDIBLE]
YU-JU HONG: Yeah, so this is
an overview of the application
I'm going to deploy today.
So the application
includes two parts.
One is a web server
hosting movie information.
This is an ASP.NET core
application, an example
that I borrowed from Microsoft.
And then we'll have a database
that's running SQL Server
Express database.
And for this, we'll be
running it in StatefulSet.
And we'll be accessing
a persistent storage.
In this case, that would be
a persistent disk in GCE.
So these two services will
share their credentials.
They have these credentials
through a Kubernetes secret.
So let's switch to the demo
to see what's going on.
So to save us some time, I
would create the GKE cluster.
The name of the cluster is demo,
and it has six nodes right now.
So let's se what's
actually in that.
So if we scroll
to the bottom, you
can see there are
two node pools.
The first one is a
default node pool, which
runs across our Linux image.
And the second one is
Win, which runs Windows.
And we can click on
that and see that it's
using Windows sac image.
And we have already
a tent that's
already applied to the node.
And let's go back to the
cluster and deploy the workflow.
So you can-- this
is another view
from using kube control, which
is Kubernetes command line
tool.
That shows that we have six
nodes right now in the cluster.
So I'm going to run
a simple script which
is just going to
deploy the specs that I
have in this directory.
So it's not doing any more than
that other than just submitting
those specs to the API server.
So while we are waiting for
the application to create,
we can actually see this
in our cloud console.
So we can see the
paths are pending,
still trying to create it.
But that's fine.
We can actually see
the spec of this--
in this case, this
is the database part.
So you can see that
it's a StatefulSet.
And in the spec, we have
environment variables
which populate and gets
the secret references
and populate environment
variables for the container
to use.
And this is running in the
SQL Server Windows Express.
And then we have the
resource limits and requests,
which are always good to have
to ensure that your node is not
overcommitted.
Next, we have the volume mounts.
So this is the part where we
want to mount the processing
storage into the
container to make sure
that we can store our data,
our log, and our backup
onto a persistent storage.
And then we have the node
selector, which is a part
that I just mentioned
in this slide
to indicate that this
is a Windows pod,
we want to run on Windows nodes.
OK, so let's go back
and check our workload.
Seems like everything is good.
And let's check the script.
Says everything
has been deployed.
So we can try and see if
we can access the website.
OK, so it works.
Now we are--
[APPLAUSE]
So we have this movie website.
We can see the details.
We can-- details of the movie.
We can actually edit
it, and everything
will be saved onto the gce-pd so
that you can recreate a new pod
and access a set of data.
So this is all good, but
what if it doesn't work?
In a lot of cases, that's
where the problem starts--
that your application doesn't
work as you expected, and you
want to troubleshoot it.
So first of all, we can
click onto the database
in the pod in this service and
actually see the CPU you memory
usage.
So it only has a
slight dot right now
because we have
only been running
this pod for a short while.
But it will gather more
data so you can easily
see what's the resource
usage of your pod right now.
And then if you want to use
Kubernetes command line tool,
that's also fine.
So we can, for example, access
the logs after the [INAUDIBLE]
right now.
So you can see is running.
They have some error message.
That seems to be fine right now.
And then if you want to
troubleshoot further,
you can also log in.
Well, you can also exact
into the container.
So right now, we are inside--
the PowerShell inside
the database container.
So for example, I can run PS and
see what processes are running.
We see the SQL Server,
SQL writer, et cetera.
And we can also try to
access the database locally.
So for now, all you
can use is SQL command.
You can write SQL queries.
So yep, let's switch
back to the slides.
So we'll be launching early
access programs soon in 2019.
So if you please sign
off with our EAP program,
you will get a chance to
actually influence our product
at the early stage
and to make sure
that we are building
what you actually need.
So let's hand it back
to Venkat to talk more
about the opportunity
that springs
to you with GKE support.
VENKAT GATTAMNENI: Thank
you so much, Yu-Ju.
It's awesome.
Thank you so much, Yu-Ju.
I'll leave this slide
at the end as well so
that you can take pictures
and then, of course sign
up for EAP.
I'm sure all of you are excited
to be joining our EAP program.
I wanted to just
spend maybe a couple
of minutes on talking about
the opportunity ahead of us.
You know, as we
talk to customers,
it's very clear
that you guys want
to run your Windows
Server container
applications with GKE.
And some of what we're
hearing from all of you
is that it's a great migration
path for your older legacy
applications.
If you're especially running
on older versions of Windows
Server-- you know, Server 2008
is going to go end of life,
end of service by January
of 2020-- many of you
are looking at opportunities
to take those applications
and modernize them.
So this is a great
opportunity for you
to containerize at the same go
without just having just, you
know, update and upgrade the
underlying operating system.
Of course, with
workload consolidation,
you can make sure that by
increasing density using
containers, you can save on the
underlying infrastructure cost
as well as say on
the licensing costs,
right, that we
talked about earlier.
And of course, I know many
of you spend a lot of time
on patching and managing your
operating systems underneath.
So with management,
with the GKE,
a lot of that sort
of overhead goes out
of the picture, which is
awesome news for all of us.
And for many of you who are
embarking on new transformation
initiatives,
modernization initiatives
at your organizations,
this is a great way
to kind of modernize
those applications, right?
So tremendous opportunity
ahead of us with Windows
Servers now coming onto GKE.
Let's talk a little
bit about next steps
in terms of how if
you're very new to GCP,
you're not yet on GCP, I
would encourage you to sign up
for a trial account.
Take Windows Server
containers for a spin
and get familiar with
the Windows Server
containers a little bit.
And of course, we
talked about how
you can sign up for the GKE
Windows Server container
support EAP.
Do sign up for that
if that's of interest.
I'm assuming, you know, by
the excitement in the room,
many of you are going to be
excited joining that program.
And of course, we have a
number of other sessions
here that we're running on
learning a little bit more
about Windows workloads on GCP
at large or GKE [INAUDIBLE]
sessions as well as
a couple of others
that we thought would
be of interest to you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]